il y a cette façon totalement
irresponsable de d'avoir
systématiquement recours à la dépense
publique
il faut limiter les aides aux
entreprises
en matière d'énergie on a pris une
solution totalement totalement folle qui
qui fait appel à des subventions alors
qu'il aurait suffit que l'État comprenne
la décision de sortir de ce marché
européen qui est totalement biaisé
totalement faussé avec un prix de marché
totalement totalement artificiel qui
repose sur le prix du gaz utilisé pour
produire de l'électricité on en serait
sorti ça nous aurait coûté 5 milliards
dessus pour subventionner le prix du gaz
utilisé pour faire de l'électricité et
une fois qu'on avait payé 5 milliards on
savait produire en France une
électricité à 50 euros le megawattheure
on sait plus on a passé du nucléaire
vous savez qu'on a redémarré avant-hier
à la centrale à charbon Saint-Avold donc
on fait encore on fait encore quand même
80% d'électricité en France on a besoin
dans n'importe 20% qu'on paye ces 20% au
prix de marché mondial et qu'on aille de
subventionnés pourquoi pas mais c'est
une aberration le choix qui a fait le
gouvernement est un choix un peu un peu
fou en tout cas pour en revenir à la
question de la dépense publique dans ce
budget c'est la raison pour laquelle on
n'a pas voté on a encore à 155 milliards
de déficits qu'on ajoute monsieur
président Macron a été plus dispendieux
que que le président Hollande pendant
tout son quinquennat et ça avant même la
crise la crise du covid donc oui on a un
vrai sujet de désaccord tout ça n'est
pas sérieux tout ça n'est pas soutenable
et avec des taux d'intérêt des eats à 10
ans à 3 %, ça devient extrêmement
dangereux merci